[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
and tonight i'm going to be taking you
through some highlights from the ongoing
tournament
in vikon zay that's right the tata steel
masters tournament i'm losing track of
how many tournaments are named
for tata steel uh but this is one of
them
in vikanze this year really interesting
stuff has been going on it's good to be
back with you guys of course the past
week and a half or so i've had some
wonderful substitutes in but i'm back in
control of the classes for now
uh and i wanted to start off with a game
that made some headlines from vikanze
which is of course andre esipenko
against magnus
carlson that's right the youngster from
russia esipenko
managed to upset the world champ with
the game we're going to take a look at
here so let's just jump into it without
further ado
we've got e4 by acepenko magnus plays
c5 knight f3 d6
we get the open sicilian
now knight f6 by magnus knight c3
and a6 everybody's favorite opening
everybody's favorite opening uh who
doesn't love a game in the night or
by magnus so let's see
how andre chose to approach this one
plays bishop e2
traditionally sort of the slower lines
and then as magnus tends to do
he opted for this e6 structure
rather than the more standard e5
nightdorf plan
of course generally the plane of the
night or play a6
take away this square from the knight
then you kick the knight away with e5
and that is how most knight dwarf games
go magnus instead
opting for the cheveningen with e6
okay we continue out with bishop e3 just
very natural development by white so far
nothing crazy
bishop e7 and then the first interesting
choice
by scpenko is to go with g4 here
so i wanted to uh stop for a second and
get the chat's thoughts
on this move of g4 what do you think
about it
this early on by white here aggressive
uh good bad perhaps
showing your cards a bit too early let
me hear your thoughts
let me hear your thoughts here
this is in fact life i can see you i can
see you
as well
elvis says not my style stupidly
aggressive looks like something sheriff
would do
in a good way so yeah it's
it's pretty aggressive right so let's
contrast this
with a more normal move like king's side
castles uh
against kingside castles you would
likely see black follow suit with
something like kingside castles as well
and you get a more normal style game
with with f4 to follow
so what is white saying with g4 well
white is saying that the king is likely
not going to be castling king's side
instead going for a more english attack
type approach with the bishop here on e3
so with g4 white is immediately looking
to
make use of a soft spot in black
structure which is this pawn on g7
additionally it's looking to chase away
this knight from its nice little outpost
on f6 for example g5 might force this
knight to some uncomfortable squares
especially if black sort of naively
played something like knight b
to d7 the most natural way to develop
perhaps now g5
leaves this knight with no good place to
go so g4 is definitely very aggressive
but the downside now is that magnus does
not have to commit the king
to castling on the king's side and that
gives black a little bit more
flexibility
so while moves like this are really
tempting to go for from
white's perspective you want to be
aggressive you want to checkmate the
opponent early
it does have a downside and i want to
point that out the downside here
is that black now sort of knows white's
entire plant
from this one move white is not going to
go back to the old slow way
of king side castling playing f4 playing
a more positional type game
white is going to play g4 and g5 and try
to rip open the g file
that being said really interesting
choice by uh scpenko
we see the move b5 by uh
by black and actually i think maybe this
isn't my my favorite move in the world
by magnus i think this is a move going
for a more double-edged game i think
probably the simplest way to respond to
the move g4 is with the move d5
right your opponent's playing on the
wing and so you can reply it by playing
in the center it's the power of having
this pawn on e6
and now of course you've dealt with the
threat of g5 by introducing the threat
of knight takes e4
now what's the downside well perhaps
things are going to simplify a bit more
after takes takes and takes and and
takes
here though i don't think black is
really going to have
too many issues at all with
the central e4 pawn being taken off the
board yes white has some active pieces
but black now is
is going to be able to develop out
perfectly fine and this is what actually
happened when naca
tried this line against topalov back in
2013.
now why doesn't magnus do this could be
a variety of reasons maybe he just
prefers the move b5
but i think likely b5 is a bit more
double-edged a bit less simplifying
and against the youngster magnus may
have been looking for a full point
so b5 played in the game no reason to
not continue with the plane here for
white
uh and scpenko plays the mu g5
of course knight g8 would not be
desirable so we see magnus retreating
this knight
back to uh d7 the only other safe square
eyeing up some central squares on e5 and
c5
as well uh now we're going to see a
really interesting move by essie panko
and that is the move a3
this is always a double-edged move in
the night or from white's perspective
and my advice for the move a3 is that
it's not a move you always want to play
it's not a move you're sort of dying to
play with the white pieces
the idea is to slow down the move b4
from black you want to stop the move b4
for the moment
but it's important to realize that a3
does not necessarily
permanently stop b4 and if you do end up
castling queenside
as it looks like white is planning to do
here with the
weak pawn on g5 soon to fall if you do
end up castling queen slide
then b4 is actually going to be a lot
stronger
with the pawn already on a3 it serves as
a hook
if black is able to to achieve the move
b4
it's going to successfully rip open some
files on the queen side and give black
a strong attack here though scpenko
willing to take the time
to play a3 for the immediate gain
of preventing the move b4 if for example
we had seen a more natural move like
queen d2 i'm pretty confident magnus
would be going for this move of b4
and then this knight simply has no good
space to go it can go out to
to a4 but it's not really happy here and
it's not exerting any pressure on
the center of the board and black is
likely going to be able to
get some simplifying traits that will
alleviate a lot of the pressure in the
position
with something like knight c5 just
immediately applying pressure
to the e4 pawn so a3 by scpenko a very
double-edged game so far
now you might be thinking to yourself g5
is attacked twice
and defended once and that is exactly
what magnus carlsen thought as well
with the move bishop takes g5 uh scpenko
follows up with queen d2
taking every moment to activate here and
this is a pretty nice move
to uh to look at if you're
sort of a more amateur level player
because it really does highlight the
idea
that to trade is is usually a mistake
whenever you trade a piece like this
voluntarily for example bishop takes g5
more often than not you serve to
activate your opponent's pieces right
you draw this queen out to the active g5
square
whereas after queen d2 we see magnus
take on e3
and now it's actually white's queen who
has been activated rather than
blacks now we're going to see magnus
sort of make the first big mistake of
the game here
honestly i had trouble deciphering this
move
when i was going through the game i
don't entirely understand
what magnus had in mind with it
especially considering the follow-up
but magnus plays the move queen h4 and i
don't know if this move
was born out of some false
sense that you could uh ever really take
on h2
maybe this is something magnus had in
mind maybe applying pressure here
some lateral pressure to the e4 pawn or
something
but this this idea just simply isn't
very good this queen isn't really making
any real threats as we'll see by white's
next move over
of rook g1 simply undefending the pawn
on h2
and saying to black yeah you're not
really going to to be taking this guy
so what's a better move instead well
likely just the simple move queen e7
uh it magnus was correct to think that
the queen needed to be activated but on
h4 it's it's simply just not
very good from e7 it's a much more solid
piece defending e7
and supporting any central breaks that's
uh black might want to go for
and it's it's just a better square for
the queen just a better square for the
queen and we're going to see that
happen in the game we have queen h4 rook
g1
g6 by black to defend the g pawn before
doing anything else
white goes on to queen side castle and
here magnus sort of realizes the mistake
with this queen out on
h4 in no man's land can't even think
about retreating back to h6 anymore
offering a queen trade because the pawn
on g7 has now moved to g6
so magnus plays the sensible move queen
e7
now with this in mind it's pretty clear
that queen h4 was a mistake
just spending an extra tempo to get back
to e7 it's a tempo that magnus is going
to wish uh
wishy had back so the game continues
with f4 we see bishop b7 by black now
king b1 by white
and at first glance you know not
everything is is so bad for black here
this
is a pretty typical looking position for
openings
like the nydorf and similar sicilians
where
you have a black for the moment stuck in
the center
white comfortably castled on the queen
side but
you know black has threats on the queen
side as well this knight can jump into
c5
we can see black finish development here
black is probably eventually going to
castle king's side anyways to bring this
other rook into the game
and really the only mistake so far is
this move queen h4 wasting a little bit
of time
giving white a one tempe tempo advantage
which could be fatal
in an opening like this but probably you
know black is still in the game
and with this in mind i'm sure magnus
pretty
comfortably plays the move knight to c6
and this is sort of the most amateurish
mistake that uh
i think magnus has made in a long time
and it's something
that i think we can all uh learn a lot
from
so with knight c6 if white were to sort
of oblige and take on c6 with the knight
and just continue out now with some idea
of doubling rooks or perhaps going h4h5
trying to to break free
black is uh still definitely in the game
right
white doesn't immediately have a
breakthrough to sort of end the game
uh no way to get at this king in the
immediate future and black can start
playing around with central
breaks playing around with the idea of
playing b4
and even perhaps castling to get the
rook into the game
but knight c6 is actually just a
straight blunder
it's just a blunder of a pawn and
andresapenko was was not about to miss
this
so what do i mean when i say this is one
of the most amateurish mistakes that
magnus has made
in a while well i have made mistakes
like this sort of countless times
when you are a beginner at chess you
always are thinking very very hard on
every single move in your serious
tournament games
because you don't want to miss any
simple tactics or even worse just
leave a piece hanging over time
you start to develop something called
board vision where the really simple
tactics you can sort of just immediately
identify you don't even have to think
about
and hanging pieces isn't really
something that you're
you're as worried about right you get to
like the 1500 level
you're pretty confident with the pieces
you're moving the pieces around
uh and you more often than not are not
going to strictly hang a piece
but this does have a downside and the
downside is
you lose some of that edge you have when
you're a beginner right when you're a
beginner
you're always on edge you're thinking
about every move you're making sure
you're not messing up the simple stuff
and you get to a point where you feel
confident in that
and you start thinking about bigger
ideas you know important plans what
you're going to do with the king
and sometimes the simple stuff just
passes you by
so let this be a word of warning nobody
is too good
to miss relatively simple tactics right
and i mean nobody because magnus
i'm sure if he had taken 10 seconds to
think here
would have spotted this tactic for white
but chat room
wait to move and get a strong advantage
what should esiepenko do
and elvis has an idea with knight takes
b5 the question is
which knight which knight i'm sure you
have the right one
but uh just to be sure just to be
thorough
ah and chess king has the wrong knight
of course
not knight d takes b5 which is just a
full sacrifice of a piece
it might not be a bad sacrifice but it's
uh even simpler than that
we should take with the knight on the
c3 square now why should white take with
the knight on the c3 square
well because of course now if the knight
on d4 were to be captured we could save
our piece
or even i i suppose take with the queen
hitting the rook
and if this pawn this piece is captured
on b5
we are not interested in merely
recapturing a pawn
but white can simply regain all of the
material with
this rather nasty fork at the end of the
day
so word of warning loose pieces tend to
drop
off this is a not uncommon tactic in
sicilians actually
where this rock any trait was left a
little bit lonely for a little bit too
long
and this is exactly how the game
continues asipanko just wins this pawn
and from here magnus has a very very
tough time of getting back
into the game sort of never really
recovers from this mistake
so that is the the lesson to take away
from this game we're going to go through
essie panko's
good technique here but never forget
you're not too good to blunder simple
tactics and
even hanging pieces right so in your
tournament games
this will save you so many so many
blunders and so much heartache
before you make your move take 20 maybe
30 extra seconds
think to yourself okay am i blundering
anything
and that that is going to save you a lot
of games uh of course
everybody tells themselves this and
everybody forgets to do it from time to
time
but make an effort to notice the simple
stuff
that that is the lesson to take away
here so essie penco does not miss his
chance takes on b5
take back on b5 take on c6 take on c6
and queen c3
with the fork uh magnus castles which is
about all you can do
and now we see estipanko picking up this
bishop on c6
uh magnus now continues out with d5
trying to
break in the center to activate the
pieces before white
totally takes over and captures the rest
of the remaining pawns
we see e takes d5 by uh white
and now magnus again uh makes makes
another
blunder here uh black needed to
immediately capture back on d5 you know
putting the pressure on this bishop and
regaining this pawn
while you still could instead we see
magnus inserting this little inner meso
here
and unfortunately this is pretty much
just the losing move just strictly the
the losing move
uh esipenko finds the nice idea of d6
and that's enough to really put magnus
out of this game
entirely d6 hitting the queen and now
this is unfortunately unplayable because
once this knight moves rook d8 check
we'll promote the pawn
don't even think about trying to defend
then it's going to have to move anyways
uh and with this the the game ends
rather quickly we see queen d8
scpeco simply picks up this pawn on b5
and now while the material is not you
know entirely out of hand
right we have one two three four five
six pawns for white four for black
the nature of the pawns is is pretty
devastating here black's pawns are
nowhere near
being relevant and white has three pawns
around the king that are ready to roll
and a super
strong past pawn here on d6
rook cb8 by magnus simply queen c4
by estepenko rook takes a3 picks up a
pawn
but in the meantime white is invading
with queen c7
queen e8 tries to keep the queens on the
board to add a little bit of intrigue
but now we see asipenko activating the
rook along the fifth rank
rook a4 rook a5 and
we see scpenko
slowly but surely reign in this game
here just activating the pieces
and using this d6 pawn as the the
winning the winning idea
rook before we see queen back to c7 now
queen f6 still trying to find
some sort of checkmating idea rook a8
though
pins this rook to the king removes any
sacrificial ideas
and that's pretty much it pretty much it
for this game queen f5
simply king b2 stepping out of the pin
rook over to b5
and that's a free piece just guarding
the c2 square now d7 and magnus carlsen
goes ahead and resigns so nothing too
too crazy by sc petko here
uh the most difficult decisions i think
essie penco really had to make were more
philosophical ones rather than chess
ones essie penco
going bold going for a bold opening
choice and
using the fact that magnus might have
been against simplifying some things
early on
to his advantage making things complex
and magnus missing the simple stuff
in this game missing the simple stuff
so questions on this game questions on
this game
isn't the first mistake the losing move
well
not necessarily you can make some
mistakes in chess and still end up
drawing the game
but when things go from bad to to
unsavable that's usually what i
kind of call the losing move
you don't see four connected pawns every
day no
and you can claim that they're connected
here but the d6 pawn is really
in a different kind of class so had to
go over this game where magnus
got destroyed by the youngster esipenko
uh but let us move on now to some
greener pastures
with fabiano carawana who is
uh approaching the lead i think geary at
the moment has the lead at the time of
recording this but uh carowanna also
very close along with some other players
i don't have the standings memorized
unfortunately but let's take a look at
this very impressive game
by fabi against ratoslaw uh
rattles i should have looked up how to
say polish names before this
uh
that was my belief and if i heard ben
simon right that's
how it's said okay we get c4 knight f6
knight f3 and d6
by fabi so bold choice here going for
king's indian structures
going for a more dark squared centro
centered plan
uh at this point uh voy chashek
vodhashek plays d4 transposing into some
more normal d4 openings
rather than english style setups we have
g6
knight c3 bishop g7 e4 and now we are
just
in a mainline king's indian defense
kingside castles and bishop e2
by white mainline stuff so far we get e5
by black kingside castles by white and
bishop g4 by fabiano carowana so this
is the bold uh
the bold move by fabi that leaves
sort of modern day theory in the king's
indian
now my understanding of this opening
with white
is that a huge downside to bishop g4 is
that it makes
knight g4 highly illegal highly illegal
to put the knight on g4 when the
bishop's already there
so in general i like to respond to this
move with bishop e3
just as a votashek does here because now
knight g4
can't be played to harass this bishop
also generally played against bishop g4
is the move d5
and this might not be the most intuitive
thing
usually when you are locking things down
it's to play against your opponent's
bishops right you want to
control these light squares so that this
bishop really has nowhere to go
in this case though you're playing d5
precisely because
black has shown interest in actually
giving up this bishop on
f3 now with the center closed
uh you can expect the game to go more
along the lines
of the traditional king's indian defense
plans where black
is expanding on the king's side going
for a checkmating attack
and white is expanding on the queen side
going for a winning advantage on that
side of the board
now why would white choose to go for
this after bishop g4
well it turns out this bishop on c8 is a
really really
important attacking piece for black in
these types of plants right you go f5 f4
the pawns control a lot of the dark
squares and the key breakthrough is
often happening on the g4 square
and this bishop is sometimes needed to
sacrifice itself on
h3 to really rip things open so without
this bishop black might find
himself having a tougher time engaging
in this attack
so a little bit of logic there for you
instead though we do see
votashek going for bishop e3 which is
sort of what i favor
in many cases fabi gives up the bishop
on f3
we see bishop takes f3 and now e takes
d4
and bishop takes d4 so so far so normal
by fabi it might not be mainline theory
but it is so far principled chess we see
black giving up the light squared bishop
for a knight
and whenever you make this kind of trade
it's often to gain control
of the other color squares right you
give up a bishop which can never attack
the dark squared central squares
in exchange for a knight which does
control those squares
and the reason you do this is to gain
control over these exact squares
and that's exactly fabi's idea he takes
on d4 to open up the bishop's axis to
these squares
and follows this up with knight c6 to
further reinforce this control
white wants to keep this bishop around
keep the bishop pair so we see bishop e3
now rookie 8 by fabi just another normal
improving move
queen d2 and knight d7 by fabi once
again
all pieces focusing in on these dark
squares now that we've given up the
bishop for the knight
we say rook a to d1 and i'm sure many of
you have seen this game before
but fabi's next move is likely one of
the most surprising moves
of uh of of the year honestly it's not a
crazy sacrifice
but it is a decision that i think zero
out of a hundred
king's indian defense players would ever
make in
in this position so chet who knows what
uh what fabi played here who knows what
fobby played
and everybody's already asking me what's
uh
why fabi did it
so yeah everybody knows everybody's seen
the game bishop takes c3
is fobby's move and this move looks sort
of obscene to uh to my eyes at first
glance i think to everybody's eyes at
first glance
this move is just ridiculous right it
goes against
all of the ideas i was just talking
about white or sorry black
gave up the light squared bishop in
order to increase control
of the dark squares that means we give
up the light squared bishop to make the
dark squared bishop
more powerful we ripped open these
squares we're controlling these squares
we're fighting for these squares
so why on earth would we give this
bishop up
after we go for this plan of dark
squared control
well the fact of the matter here is that
uh
by giving up the light squared bishop of
course we've given up some control
of the light squares as well and what
this means
is that white is looking to build a very
powerful knight here
uh in the center with this knight on d5
that's just sort of undeniable this
knight is going to be very strong in the
center of the board
and black is going to be hard pressed to
play a move like c6 to kick it away
when facing so much pressure down the
d-file
so what fabi does is simply takes this
knight off of the board
now does this actually mean fabi is
abandoning
the original plan of controlling the
dark squares in the center
not necessarily and i think that is sort
of the heart
of uh this decision by fabi
uh fabi decided that he didn't need this
bishop
on g7 in order to control the dark
squares in the center of the board
all fabi wants to do is occupy these
squares with the knights
and that's exactly what happens moving
forward
so by taking off this knight on c3 yes
for the moment it looks like there are
irreparable
uh dark squared holes in black's
position but fabi is relying on both of
the knights
in order to sort of plug up these gaps
and ensure that that nothing goes wrong
so
bishop takes c3 yes it goes against the
idea of controlling the dark squares
but in this case fabi is simply aiming
to slow down white's counter play with
moves like knight d5 and pressure down
the d
file in order to give himself time to
use the knights effectively
to stop up the center and play against
the bishops
so not something you see every day black
willingly giving up both bishops so
so early on but fabi here is simply
looking to make the knights powerful he
has
very concrete ideas for where these
knights are going to go
and giving up the bishop for the night
may look positionally bad
but it does effectively slow down
white's play
and give fabi time to sort of enact some
of these plants
we see fabi continuing now with uh queen
to f6
and i think this is probably the the
best example uh
the best follow-up move to show fabi's
idea even without this bishop on g7
bobby is still effectively contesting
these dark squares in the center of the
board
and proving that even without the bishop
fabi's in control
of this diagonal and of these squares
and you see that with whitesnake's move
of queen c1
despite not having the bishop on g7
bobby is still able to play queen
f6 take over this diagonal and that's
what really matters here
uh it matters that fabia is able to take
over
this sort of open color of squares while
white's light squared bishop on the
other hand
still remains hampered by white's own
pawns
up next knight c5 by fabi so far so good
all according to the plan white now
doesn't even have time to begin
attacking
on these dark squares because these
knights are too powerful
attacking the e4 uh the e4 pawn so we
see
the slightly awkward looking queen b1 by
white
uh now a kind of strange move by fabi
is queen to e6 the idea is pretty simple
though you just attack both of these
pawns at the same time
at least that was my understanding of it
rook f to e1
by votashek and queen takes c4 so fabi
going up a pawn
now we play a little game of dancing
around
where we see b3 hitting the queen queen
c3
bishop d2 hitting the queen queen back
to f6 and again
you see that even without the bishop it
is in fact fabiano
who has control over the dark squares in
the center of the board
bishop c1 by votashek now aims to prove
that this
is not lasting and this is the danger
that you face
whenever you give up your dark squared
bishop even if for the moment
you're able to keep control over this
dark square diagonal
more often than not against an unopposed
bishop
it's going to find its way onto that
diagonal one way or another
and then you're going to have a pretty
tough time of keeping control of
everything so bishop c1 by votashk i
think is the right idea
aiming to put this bishop on b2 and
highlight the fact that this bishop
is missing fabi does not panic though
and we see h5
bishop b2 by white and of course now
knight to e5
is the follow-up so bobby's plan has
sort of been enacted
uh pretty much perfectly up to this
point
despite not having the bishop fabio was
able to maintain temporary control
over the important central dark squares
and now
that white has finally re-maneuvered to
contest the squares with the bishop it's
already cost white a pawn
and fabi is successfully still stopping
up the center with a very powerful
knight on e5
and putting pressure uh on the rest of
white's position
with this knight on c5 and now with the
king side expansion
uh okay we see bishop b2 so so far so
good for fabi like like i've been saying
in the short term
he controlled the dark squares now that
white has repositioned
uh black has been able to stop
up the dark square diagonal with all of
its weaknesses
but the question now is how should we
follow up
so so far so good pat yourselves on the
back if you're fabiano carowana here
but the game's definitely not over
you're up upon
but you need to find some way to
keep the bishops at bay and also sort of
advance your own interests
so what can we do with black here what's
our next
step
why not bishop g5 earlier by whites uh
i believe it would run into trouble with
the e4 pawn
i sort of said vaguely i can show you
some specifics
a moment later why retreat the knight
was pinned
uh well for one the bishop on f3 doesn't
really make a good impression it doesn't
do a lot there
and number two there was actually a
threat because knight takes f3 would
would come with check but yeah white's
looking to to reroute this guy
to a more active square somewhere over
here maybe
so yeah don't just give me a move give
me sort of black's
continuing plan here from here on out
there's a couple things that are
really really important to keep in mind
so yeah the chat room pretty much has
both ideas here
um the first thing you really need to
keep in mind is
you will pretty pretty much certainly
lose the game
if you allow white to play the move f4
like let's say we play a couple
nonchalant moves
maybe something like rookie 7 aim to
double let's say
queen c1 by white i'll say rook a to d8
if if f4 comes on okay well sorry i
shouldn't just hang a piece like this
let's say queen e6
and f4 comes on the board anyways right
if you allow f4
in this position by white you're you're
just gonna get killed you're gonna get
killed your knight has to move
and like you're gonna get killed on the
dark squares just trust me you're going
to get murdered you're going to get
slaughtered
on the dark squares if you allow f4 so
priority number one has to be making
sure that white is
never able to play this move right we
have to make sure
we maintain our grip on the dark squares
otherwise all those chest
principles we've we've always been
taught in the king's indian don't give
up this bishop in front of your king
they will be true you'll get slaughtered
without this bishop if white is able to
break open this diagonal so we need to
stop f4 priority number one
in number two the way to advance black's
own interests here
are not necessarily to try and push the
majority of the pawns on the queen side
but to continue what fabi started with
the move h5 which is launching some kind
of kingside attack here
why don't we want to really do anything
with these phones over here
well for one we like having this pawn
on d6 to support these dark squares it's
sort of needed
to be there in order to keep this bishop
at bay
and number two moves like a5 and
a4 might not be the worst in the world
but
uh in the meantime again keeping f4 at
bay is priority number one
playing moves like a5 and a4 really does
nothing to help prevent
f4 so playing on the king side is
definitely
how black is going to continue here with
always of course this f4 idea
in mind so we see h4 being the first
move played by fabi
queen c1 is what votashek decides to
play
and of course now the only real response
by black well i guess you can go 96 as
well but g5
is is the nice follow-up and this is
something you shouldn't be afraid to do
in king's indian positions and also
benoni positions
uh this being the move g5
very very often uh your position
revolves around having a strong piece
on e5 in those openings as we do here
right if this net on e5
has to go away then black's going to
lose the game so
we play the move g5 to control the move
to control the f4 square and ensure that
this guy is going to stay
stick around rather permanently so super
super important move
of g5 we see bishop b5 as a follow-up by
vatashik
fabi simply lifts the rook up nothing to
fear rook e3 by votashek is going
for some third ranked defense but by
this point it's
pretty clear who is on the back foot
here fabi has a little bit of room
to maneuver around on the king's side
and it's tough to find an active plan
for white like what is white meant to do
if you can't achieve
f4 what are you doing with your pieces
not so clear queen g6 is what fobby
decides to do putting pressure on
e4 and clearing the way for an eventual
uh
f pawn break also just supporting the g
pawn bishop e2
by votasyk retreating the bishop back
but now rook over
to e8s and yeah this pressure on the e
pawn
definitely mounting queen c2 to defend
and now we do see chess king's idea of
knight e6 heading into f4
and at this point uh
objectively white is definitely still in
the game
but i think in a practical over the
board game this
is a very very very tough position
for white to handle these knights are
just sort of
plugging up the entire position you have
no activity and black's plans are very
very clear
so chat room i want to ask you about the
move
bishop takes e5 is this something worth
considering
for white should white consider taking
this super strong knight here on e5
what do you think
elvis says definitely
great wolf says yeah
it's heading to f4 well this one's
heading to f4 but we can't take that one
we can take the one on e5 though
definitely consider it so yeah i think
this is an idea that white definitely
has to have in mind
and it's something that black should not
uh forget about either
now in this specific position uh i think
it
is going to leave white with some very
very significant troubles
and maybe isn't even the best way
forward
what's the problem with it well after d
takes e5 it's true that you got rid of
one powerful
knight but even as you activate this
bishop now the knight's gonna land on d4
and honestly this should be enough for
for a winning advantage here
uh the centralized knight rather than
the knight on f4 which is a little more
localized to the king's side
this knight is just going to be too
powerful and like you're going to have
to give up a rook for it eventually
or suffer the consequences so bishop
takes c5 definitely a move you have to
keep in mind
but really important to note how it
changes the structure
now black is not only confined to the f4
square but knight d4 is playable as well
and this is going to be very very strong
for
for black that being said let's follow
down the engine line a little bit and
we'll see
a little bit of changes here the engine
wants white to play the move
h3 stopping the move g4 for the moment
and then just some random improving move
for black such as king to h7
let's say king h1 wait a second hold on
i lost my line i lost my line
let's say something like uh king h7
b4 for white sort of expanding on the
queen side
knight f4 is a follow-up and after the
move knight f4 it does make a lot of
sense to go for
bishop takes e5 and here you might see
some some
simplifications where white might
actually stand a chance
of uh not losing this game so bishop
takes e5
definitely on the cards for uh
for white you just have to make sure
you're timing it right now you might be
asking why not just try to go for the
same stuff with knights
e6 to d4 and the problem here is that
you likely aren't ever going to get it
because this bishop is going to take the
knight the second it lands on east
or well here maybe you hang a queen but
um
yeah the second this knight lands on e6
white is going to be looking
to capture it so important
idea for white though is definitely
bishop takes on e5
i wanted to highlight that so f3 instead
played by white and we do see knight f4
played by fabi now once again this idea
is coming a little bit too late because
d takes e5 is going to be strong here
without black having committed to uh
to any other moves and white already
having committed to f3 this is sort of
why
f3 is worse than h3 because here this
bishop is
really really hemmed in by its own pawns
so instead we see bishop back to f1
now c6 is a good move by fabi keeping
the c
file under control yes it does weaken
the pawn on d6 but we'll see that fabi
actually has
other ideas in mind queen f2
rook up to e6 rook c3 and then
i'd like for you to stop for a second
and
tell me what you think fabi is going for
here
because this is a move that i think a
lot of you
would struggle to come up with maybe not
though maybe you're all
super geniuses could be
the vacation was good the vacation was
good gus
thanks for asking thanks again though to
all the wonderful substitutes
that hopped in over the past week and a
half you got quite a rotating cast
specialist ghost says h3 obviously
exquisite corpse
says i think he wants to push d5
and that's exactly correct here so fabia
sort of
increased his king side control to the
maximum right these knights are all
amazing
they control the knights situated on the
dark squares
are attacking the light squares in
white's camp and black's pawns
situated on also in the dark squares are
controlling the dark squares so
black is essentially fighting for every
single square on the king's side right
like all these squares
are under threat by uh by black's pieces
so
with things sort of at their best on
the king's side fabi now looks to rather
controversially
break some things open because these
knights are so powerful
he is able to actually open the position
against the bishops which is something
you normally
do not want to do because the bishop
simply can't make use
of the opening right so with that
fabi does play the move d5 and i said
this is a move that a lot of people
might struggle to come up with
because again opening the position
against the bishops is something really
difficult to do
and is rarely correct but here i think
this is sort of
at least to my eyes surprising move
number two by fabi in this game
surprising move number one
definitely bishop takes c3 but d5 as
well i think deserves an honorable
mention because
opening the position is pretty tough
uh now as for specifics why is it so
okay for fabi to open the position here
well because the diagonals that fabi is
opening
are very very clearly already controlled
by
black's knights so it's not as if this
bishop is going to be landing on one of
these diagonals anytime soon
because fabi just has such a permanent
grip on the position
so d5 really good move by fabi such a
good move that votashek doesn't even try
to take on d5 although maybe he should
have instead we see the move g3
and watashik is trying to gain back
control of this uh this king side here
see h takes g3 by fabi uh h takes g3
by votashek and now
foggy plays a pretty interesting move
here turns out there is actually a
better way to continue
with the move g4 this is probably the
best way to sacrifice this piece
and the idea is simply that we take this
with check
and this is just unfortunate this is
just very very unfortunate for
white won't get into too many details
because it wasn't played in the game
and what fabio played is also very very
interesting with d takes e4 just
sacrificing the knight
in this manner and this was the point of
uh fabi's playing d5 he knew that this
grip
on the king's side wasn't going to be
permanent and so
at the risk of opening up some files or
diagonals for the bishops
bobby uh played rather immediately to
take even more
and take advantage of the strong
placement of the knights while they were
able to stay
you can kind of contrast this with a
move like knight h5
which would obviously be a lot simpler
so what happens with knight h5
well first and foremost white is going
to take on d5
and start challenging the the center of
the board again right bring the rooks
to the center make sure that
black doesn't sort of have a
monopolistic control
over the open file and eventually
if you see uh these pieces sort of
getting retreated
let's just play a few example moves here
let's say black wastes some time
you might even see some ideas of f4
coming back to light
might even see some ideas of f4 coming
back to light maybe i should stop
hanging
tactics though but just a word of
warning if
black takes too long the grip on the
king's side is not necessarily permanent
and white is definitely going to look to
remove this knight from the e5 square
and make use of this bishop okay
enough of that though because fabi is
not a weak player d takes e4
now unfortunately white really doesn't
have much choice in the matter if white
plays the move f takes e4
now i do believe we would see the simple
knight h5
and the key difference here is that
white is no longer ever going to play
the move f4 on account of having no
f pawn pretty major obstacle
uh and in the meantime fabi's going to
play the move g4
completely take over the light squares
in front of white's king
and this pawn's weak and the knights are
still very strong
and are not going to be kicked away uh
anytime soon
so white's pretty much committed here in
votesheck's mind
votashek's mind and we see g takes f4
unfortunately though this does just just
lose the game
g takes f4 check by fabi queen g2 trying
to trade
now e takes on f3 we get queen takes g6
rotates g6
with check now unfortunately
the desirable move of king f2 actually
loses
and i would like the chat room to tell
me why this wasn't actually played in
the game
so might be an interesting puzzle for
those of you who have even seen it
king f2 and white tries to escape with
the extra piece
black has three f-pawns it's impressive
ray lopez says i'm already over 2000
uscf elo
well the good news is the road to 2000
can be uh for for any any rated player
we'll get you back to 2000. i promise
ray lopez
even if you're over 2000 we can get you
back down there
barring any ridiculous rules like floors
raiding floors
ridiculous knight g4 something something
checkmate has been said
and not quite not quite
knight g4 actually blows it knight g4
blows it if you go knight g4 too early
white's gonna escape king takes f3 and
one by one your f pawns are going to
fall
[Music]
knight g4 rookie 3 is not checkmate
it's definitely not checkmate so
of course the answer here is to set up
your mating
nets rook to g3 is actually the only
winning move against king to f2
and maybe this is one of the lines that
might have slipped past votashek
rook g3 in this king simply has nowhere
to go now knight g4 check is coming
and that will be doom king e1 is really
the only move to keep the game going and
now really
anything is winning here not the least
of which
includes uh just taking the the free
bishop can you see two for
well this rook's hanging you try
something like rook here
you get some fun stuff like this
king c1 and queens
so king f2 rook g3 the killer move with
knight g4
checkmate being threatened fun stuff
knight 4 check first though king takes
f3 and white is actually
in the game important to note anyways of
course both players saw this and so
watashi goes for king h1 instead which
does a better job of surviving
but now the f pawns show their might
with the move
f2 and now threats of rookie 1 and rook
g1
are impossible to stop bishop h3
by votashik tries to guard against dirk
g1 check
now we see knight c4 pretty killer move
by fabi here
hitting the bishop on b2 and
against rook takes c4 or b takes c4 we
get rookie one check
and here votashik decided to throw in
the towel
if the king moves of course you just
simply take the rook and promote the
pawn
and if rook takes of course we just make
a queen and that is the end
of the game so really really impressive
game here
by fabi one that seemingly breaks all of
the rules
bobby not a rule follower rule breaker
uh
in order to to get some interesting
positions here
so what's the the takeaway from this
game well first of all don't mess with
fabiano caruana
second of all this move bishop takes c3
uh really really unintuitive moves can
sometimes be correct
but as always whenever you break a
principle
you have to be absolutely certain you
know what you're doing
here bobby is allowed to give up the
dark squared bishop
because he has such a lasting control
over the dark squares
with the knights in the center of the
board if you don't follow up this move
with the very active ideas that fabi did
to take back those dark squares even
without the bishop then black is simply
going to be losing
so really really important to realize
when you give up this bishop with bishop
g4
and bishop takes f3 you are sort of pot
committed
to going after the dark squares in the
center of the board just because bobby
plays bishop takes c3
doesn't mean he gave up on the dark
squares
secondly when you have improved your
position to the maximum
do not dilly dally right fabi's position
improved to the maximum here the knights
on their ideal squares the pawns
entirely pushed forward bobby does not
dilly dally instead
goes c6 and pushes for d5 trying to
expand
further and those are the two main
points i really wanted to highlight with
this game
along we're just showing a really really
impressive game by uh by fabi here so
other questions about this game before
we move along
before we move along
gustavo's game has been deleted
unfortunate that is a problem
only you can solve
am i going on twitch so yes this is of
course the roger 2000 right after the
2000 on youtube we still have the
end game class on youtube and after that
class
then we move on over to twitch for
analyze your games
was king g7 not playable at some point
to try to meet with rick h okay
we'll take a quick look and then move on
here so
at this point white does have a little
bit of third ranked defense
with this rook here on c3 king g7 is
maybe not advisable
on account of uh the bishop still being
here
and yeah it's sort of a situation of
uh one win is enough right one winning
one win is enough any king g7
even moves like this taking advantage of
the pin could be quite good
all right let us move along then i want
to highlight one more game
and what game shall we pick here what
game shall we pick i guess let's do
the good old-fashioned carlson ferrugia
game from round
one so of course magnus having a little
bit of an up and down tournament with
that one loss
but as always mr consistent
is the world champion and uh i think
he's back to a plus one score
at the time of recording and he started
off actually
with a win against furuja so i wanted to
highlight this i will go through it a
little bit quicker because we are
running
out of time but we have a queen's gambit
with a early knight b to d7 bishop g5
h6 bishop h4 bishop b7
and c takes d5 so we get a rather
simplified position here
where black is able to play knight takes
d5
on account of this tension between the
bishops generally
i will say if you have to take back on
d5 with the pawn
you should normally just take with the
pawn first usually trading this knight
for this knight is not always ideal
in this case though if knight takes d5
black it doesn't even necessarily have
to take on d5
with the ideas of bishop takes h4 being
included although i should say maybe
here
black's best idea is probably just to
take this anyways but the point now
is that these bishops come off the board
as well and that's the relevant factor
all right brief aside uh over we get
bishop take c7 queen takes e7 in the
game
and now e4 by magnus we get knight takes
c3
b takes c3 castles bishop d3
c5 castles take on d4 take on d4 and b6
so
this is the first moment when i want to
pause because this is a pro
a pretty common situation in a lot of
queens gambits and a lot of grunfeld's
of course as well the difference with
the grunfeld here being
no bishop on g7 but it is a typical
grunfeld structure so with the white
pieces here
what should you do what should you do
right at the surface
it seems like you control all the
central squares you should be crushing
it
but the question always that arises
is how do you actually make use of your
central advantage
so chat room what do you think how
should we make use of our central
advantage
so a couple ideas from the chat room and
some of them are quite good
the point i want to highlight here is
that
i'm going to say some controversial
stuff now get ready controlling the
center
is not the end-all be-all of chess
okay all right you've heard it here
first now what do i mean by that
well it's true that white controls the
center
but controlling the center is actually
just a tool
in many cases towards activating your
pieces
so if you can't activate your pieces and
your opponent
can activate their pieces it doesn't
really matter
if you have this slight little central
advantage so what does that mean
for this game well black has a very
clear idea to activate the pieces by
playing bishop b7
and knight f6 in the meantime white's
pieces aren't necessarily bad
but there's no real advantage in
activity to be spoken of here
black has managed to trade off two sets
of minor pieces
which means the central advantage isn't
really all that
hampering towards black's position black
is perfectly fine activating the two
remaining minor pieces but should be
seven and knight f6
so white shouldn't actually be all that
better here and that's something that i
think can be
kind of difficult to understand right
we're told from very very early on
you control the center you get an
advantage right white controls the
center undoubtedly here
central advantage but it's not enough
for a positional advantage here
because black again has very comfortable
squares for the remaining minor pieces
so let that be
an opening lesson to you all right just
because you control the center doesn't
mean you deserve to be better
you need to use the center to get an
advantage
in activity so what magnus does here is
not try to push through in the center
immediately and does find a nice
activating plan
of his own to help disrupt the black
pieces
with a4 black continues with the natural
plan of bishop b7
but magnus's point now is that we're
going to get at this bishop a little bit
on b7 by ripping open some of these
queen side files
frozer chooses b takes a5 we get rook
takes a5
and now again knight f6 very natural
plan by black
we get rook to e1 guarding the attacked
pawn rook f to d8
and now queen a1 by magnus
and rather than do anything with the
center again magnus is sort of just
leaving it to sit there and starts
harassing black
on the queen side of the board we see
queen c7
by ferruja and small point now
is that this is not really the end of
the world for black
because this queen gets almost entirely
trapped after rook a8
and we would see some simplifications
into a a very fine end game for uh
for black here black doesn't really have
any problems at all
so magnus chooses not to take this pawn
instead just plays the move
uh h3 we see a6 by faruja putting the
pawn on the light square where it can be
defended
by the bishop rook over to c5 now
queen to f4 and again zooming on past as
we are short on time
rookie 597 hits the rook rook moves back
to a5
a little bit of shuffling here knight f6
and finally a key move
d5 by magnus so again
just sitting there with the center
forever is
not a way to prove an advantage having
central
uh control is only an advantage if you
can use it
to activate your own pieces or disrupt
your opponent's pieces and that's
exactly
what magnus aims to do here with a very
interesting
pawn sacrifice so before d5 black's
pieces
active attacking this pawn on e4 giving
white
problems after d5 it's true e takes d5
and black wins the pawn but now after e5
knight e4 this bishop starts to look a
little bit less
active magnus has given up a very strong
central pawn
but has effectively stunted this bishop
locked it out of the game
so giving up the advantage in the center
for that advantage in activity
that magnus has been seeking all along
now we see the move queen d4
and the tide starts to turn here the
tide starts to turn a little bit it's
true
farrugia has an extra pawn in the center
of the board
pretty good stuff but magnus now is
successfully activating
all the pieces and we see our first
problem piece here
for ferrugia rook dc8 is the follow-up
now taking control of the open file
rook a to a1 is allowing the rooks to
maneuver a little bit more freely on the
first rank
a5 by ferija trying to make use of this
extra pawn
rook a to b1 and again we see magnus is
aiming
to harass black's coordination bishop c6
and now the key move number two of the
game by magnus
is e6 and that's why i wanted to
highlight this game i found it really
really striking
how magnus has these two strong central
pawns and then
in turn sacrifices both of them to give
black
two central pawns and it goes to show
controlling the center
really really important but that doesn't
necessarily mean
you have an advantage unless it results
in peace
activity so faruji takes back on e6
but now magnus's point is that the e5
square has been vacated
and in fact magnus is still the one with
the central advantage here
despite black having the centralized
pawns these two pieces
really really strong in the center this
piece pretty awful
in the center not in the center to be
honest with you and
uh objectively black is probably doing
fine because two extra pawns has two
extra pawns
but in an over the board game as i
always say it's not always
so simple we saw queen f6 in the game
and now magnus plays f3 looking to
harass this knight away
we get knight g5 and rook b6 and
again two pawns is two pawns but we see
now
magnus has successfully harassed all of
black's pieces
and is going to be the one with the
piece activity advantage here
rookie 8 played in the game and magnus
starts to maneuver over to the king's
side to make some threats
we get a4 knight g4 hitting the queen
queen d8s and an exchange sacrifice by
magnus
knight takes e6 queen takes e6 with
check and farouza makes
sort of his first really major and also
final
mistake with the move bishop f7 and this
is simply losing
to the tactical combination that magnus
finds if black had played the move king
to h8
uh black would definitely still be in
the game here uh
and would just have to look forward to
defending
uh against a pretty devastating attack
for the the near future sort of for
the the permanent future here defending
against stuff like this
so instead though bishop f7 and the
knockout blow if you want to try to find
at home go ahead and
pause the video here but i am just going
to show it the move
is knight takes h6 with check for king
king and bishop
black is forced to capture and now the
simple queen takes h6
and there's just no escaping with this
king white controls the escape route
through the e file and the yeah the king
just has nowhere to go
if russia tried queen c7 now we get
queen h7 check
queen hha check bishop g8 and queen h6
check
was enough for ferruccia to throw in the
towel
if you try to go queen g7 we switch
sides
make use of the fact that we control e7
and deliver
checkmate and if you come up with the
king simply bishop g6 check
and we actually walk the king down the f
file here and can even checkmate with
the pawn if we so desire
so really impressive game by magnus uh
the takeaway i wanted
to to show to you guys here is this idea
of you know controlling the center being
great and all but unless
it results in some sort of hampering
effect on your opponent's pieces
on their activity it doesn't do a great
deal for you
so magnus expertly using the center to
hamper black's pieces
activate his own pieces led to a winning
position
in this game impressive practical chess
by the world champion
that is going to do it for us here
tonight though on the road to 2000
again if you want some more chess
tonight we're going to switch on over to
the
end game class now and after that we
will continue live on twitch with
analyze your games
uh with that being said thank you all so
much for watching
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
you